حالة محتملة الخطورة في
محطة الفضاء الدولية ،
فقدت المحطة الفضائية
السيطرة لمدة ساعة بعد أن أخطأت وحدة روسية مرسخة حديثًا في
محركات الدفع الخاصة
بها ، كانت ساعة مثيرة للغاية ولكن
نظرًا لاستعداد الفريق ،
كان الطاقم جاهزًا
لعمليات الطوارئ التي تم
إجراؤها وكنا قادرين على  من الصعب العودة إلى رحلة فضائية ذات
تكوين مستقر وآمن
، وعندما
نوفر إمكانات جديدة ،
يمكن أن تكون هناك بعض الثغرات ولهذا السبب
نستعد ونتدرب على هذه الحالات الطارئة
، تصفها بأنها ساعة مثيرة للغاية
مرعبة في الواقع الاتصالات
بين الأرض ورواد الفضاء السبعة.
ضاع لمدة 11 دقيقة
تقارير فرصة ماثيو من موسكو من موسكو
صباح الخير كريستين ولورا نحن
والمسؤولون الروس يقولون إن أفراد الطاقم السبعة
على متن المحطة الفضائية
لم يكونوا في أي خطر أبدًا ، لكن
عطل الصاروخ
حدث بعد عدة ساعات من إرساء وحدة Nolca
التي تم إطلاقها مؤخرًا
بالإصدار  في يوم
الخميس
بعد رحلة فضاء طويلة استمرت ثمانية أيام  ht
للوصول إلى هناك
تقول ناسا إن وحدات الدفع بدأت في
إطلاق النار
عن غير قصد وبشكل غير متوقع مما أدى
إلى تحريك المحطة
45 درجة بعيدًا عن موقفها لعدة
دقائق أثناء الحادث
، يبدو أن الاتصالات قد فقدت
مع المحطة الفضائية
ولكن ناسا تقول إن عمليات الاسترداد قد
صححت
الموقف والإصدار هو  مرة أخرى في عرض أسعار جيد
، كان من المفترض أن يتم
إطلاق وحدة nauka الروسية التي يبلغ وزنها 20 طنًا والتي قامت بتحديث المختبر ومناطق المعيشة في عام 2007 ،
لكن التأخيرات والتخفيضات في الميزانية
لبرنامج الفضاء الروسي
أدت إلى تأجيلها حتى الأسبوع الماضي فقط